borrowers are feeling the squeeze with
Rising interest rates as inflation
remains High well on the flip side one
real estate agent is offering some ways
to offset those higher costs
seven percent should not scare people
even giavi is looking to buy a home in
Las Vegas and a separate property as an
investment I like the fact that it's tax
wise is advantageous like many GI saw
the explosive growth in Las Vegas on
Thursday the average cost on a 30-year
fixed rate home loan according to
Mortgage Firm Freddie Mac 7.08 percent
up 0.14 percent from last week and 3.94
from last year according to Alex Vasquez
with exp Realty this means affordability
is reduced for all buyers however smart
buyers are purchasing the buying down
the interest rate so they're getting
Savvy they're putting it down a certain
amount of
money down for for the property and
they're buying down points to make that
payment more affordable UNLV assistant
professor of Economics Nicholas Irwin
says we could see rates continue to
climb as the federal government tries to
tame inflation we have some other things
that make us very attractive for
businesses to move in for example or you
know those state income taxes as many
feel the burden on their wallet Vasquez
explains the average home price in Las
Vegas is four hundred and fifty thousand
dollars buyers should note there are
many programs in Nevada that can help
renters become homeowners I would hold
off maybe another two three months
but these are the best time to buy
wellvaska says interest rates can also
be refinanced down the road to help
reduce your payment later and as for
those with credit card debt experts say
consider transferring your debt to a
zero interest card and if possible pay
off your balance